[Music]
I'm really excited to learn from you
about stackdriver transparent sy
monitoring can you tell me a little bit
about this demo absolutely
so what we're demoing here is one of the
capabilities and one of the products in
stackdriver suite and what we're doing
here it actually is enabling developers
and operational people to monitor their
services are getting from Google so for
instance if your application is
involving multiple pieces inside Google
Cloud say spanner or a big table or
bigquery every API call that you are
making to Google is something that we
measure and we give you the information
about what we see so in that case if
something goes wrong and you need
something that one able you to know
what's going on we're going to give you
the Google side of things so if
something on the Google side is
malfunctioning or is misbehaving
we'll be transparent and give you the
information about how Google is treating
you excellent and so I think you might
have answered my next question but what
is it that makes this helpful and useful
to developers oh that's actually a great
question so think about the fact that if
you have an application that you own and
your application is composed of your
code as an application server but it
relies on services from Google and it
makes API calls to certain pieces of the
of the infrastructure you would want to
know first and foremost when something
happens to you have a long latency oh
you have a lot of error messages or your
customer is complaining about something
you want to be able to to pinpoint the
right area where the problem is and so
we give you the indication how the
underlying services of Google are
behaving and if this is the case get to
know where to focus your attention first
get in touch with Google to fix the
problem that we have on our side or
focus on your application which is
actually misbehaving and the the api's
are actually behaving correctly okay
excellent well thank you so much for
sharing a little bit about the demo and
[Music]